Mark Salling has struck a plea deal in  his child pornography case on Wednesday  the former Glee star agreed to plead  guilty to possession of child  pornography involving a prepubescent  minor and will be sentenced to four to  seven years in prison according to court  documents obtained by et selling we'll  also have to register as a sex offender  and enter a treatment program the actor  was arrested in December 2015 after  investigators found quote thousands of  images and videos depicting child  pornography on his laptop a hard drive  and a USB flash drive seized from his  home in June of last year selling was  indicted on two charges of receiving and  possessing child pornography days after  his indictment he was fired from his gig  on the miniseries @ gods and secrets